[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing voldemort
horcruxes souls sauron and the one ring
from the lord of the rings series more
specifically
we're going to be taking a look at how
sauron's ring compares
to voldemort's horcruxes comparing and
contrasting
magical worlds is fun particularly the
works of tolkien
rolling as there are more parallels than
you might think
rowling is quite open about her
inspiration from the world around her
and how she leveraged it to create a
world of her own
and create a world of her own she did
but that's not to say that there aren't
elements of harry potter
that also exist quite similarly in other
franchises
i've always been the first and foremost
a harry potter fan but that certainly
doesn't mean that i don't enjoy
other franchises and lord of the rings
is just another of the franchises that
i've always loved
with that being said being a fan of both
it'd be hard not to notice similarities
between the two
and one thing in particular that i want
to talk about is just how similar
sauron's ring is to voldemort's
horcruxes i mean
voldemort even has a horcrux that's also
a ring
jk rowling who coined horcrux defines
them as
a receptacle prepared by dark magic in
which a dark wizard has intentionally
hidden a fragment of his soul
for the purpose of attaining immortality
essentially they are soul containers
objects onto which the dark wizard or
witch in question
have successfully imparted a piece of
themselves
voldemort did it in harry potter but
what you probably never thought about is
that sauron
did basically the same thing the tale of
the lord of the rings is very much
centered around
the one ring a central plot element and
ring of great power
that was created by the dark lord sauron
in the fire of orodrin
during the second age sauron the main
antagonist and lord of the rings
made the ring in order to gain dominion
over the free peoples of middle earth
disguised as anata he aided the elvin
smiths of arakion
in making the rings of power however one
particularly interesting aspect of
sauron's creation of the one ring
is that he poured himself into the
magical artifact before setting off on
his quest from back end
gandalf tells frodo the following saron
made that ring himself
it is his and he let a great part of his
own former power
pass into it so he put a part of himself
and his power into the ring
but does that include his soul here's
the thing
lord of the rings approaches it a little
bit differently and it isn't quite as
simple as
he put his soul into it according to the
silmarillion
sauron placed his strength and will into
the ring
which sort of means that while it
doesn't contain his soul
the ring is still an extension of
himself and in effect
works the same way that a horcrux does
for example
like with horcruxes those who come into
contact with the object
end up suffering in lord of the rings we
see those who bear the ring
become paranoid and neurotic and in
harry potter
like we see with ron in the deathly
hallows those who bear a horcrux for too
long
can similarly become paranoid it's hard
to ignore the commonalities between
these objects
and i think that it makes for quite an
interesting comparison do you see
sauron's ring like one of voldemort's
horcruxes
did you ever think about this let me
know in the comment section
below until next time it does not do to
dwell on dreams
and forget to live